Holy Usopp! What a perfectly juicy chapter to
leave us with for the upcoming 4 week hunger
streak. Oda-sensei really gave us a ton of meat to
chew on while we wait for the story to continue.
And thank god, we didn't actually end up rushing
out of Wano within two chapters, but will get
some more time to wrap things up properly. Let's
begin with the new bounties we have gotten. Luffy,
Law and kid all have received an absolutely
ridiculous bounty of 3 BILLION berries, making
all three of them more wanted than Blackbeard.
I think this bounty reveal is a big suprise in
a number of ways. I'm sure there many people
who expected it to be a lot higher than this,
including me. But honestly, I really love
3 Billion for a number of reasons. When
you really think about it, it makes a ton
of sense. Putting Luffy above Blackbeard
underlines really nicely how impactful his
victory over Kaido was. Yes Blackbeard killing
off Whitebeard and taking his devil fruit
shook the world, but Whitebeard was sick,
old and had already been fighting against
the strongest fighters in the marines. Luffy
meanwhile was facing off against a significantly
younger Kaido, still in his prime and known as the
most powerful creature in the world. And yes,
Kaido also was fighting against the scabbards,
Yamato and 5 of the supernova at once, but in the
end LUffy was really the one who did over 90% of
the damage it took to take him down. So a bounty
higher than Teach makes sense. Now you could argue
that Luffy deserves a bounty higher than Kaido
for taking him down. Instead of Kaido's 4Billion,
the much quoted 5,6Billion, go mu, in line
with luffy's gomu gomu no mi. Only that
we now know that there actually is no GOmu GOmu no
mi. So I think that this particular wordplay might
well be off the table now. The fact that taking
down both Kaido and Big Mom took a major team
effort, in my opinion justifies a lower bounty
than them. Again, just because Teach took out
WHitebeard, doesn't mean that he got a 6Billion
bounty afterwards. Luffy usually got a highter
bounty than his opponent, because he took them out
at full strength. An antagonist like Katakuri for
instance started at full health against Luffy. So
raising his bounty higher than theirs makes sense,
at least from the outside perspective. Morgan and
the government didn't really know what was going
on in the mirror world. However CP0 was reporting
every last detail about the raid to the outside
world. So the bounty could be adapted a lot more
precisely. On top of that, putting Luffy above
Kaido's level would also have put him above
Shanks, who has been a Yonko for much longer
than Luffy. I would assume that you would have to
repeatedly do crazy things like this, to actually
raise your bounty even further. Maybe Luffy will
overtake Shanks after they have actually met
in the story, which would make a lot more sense
narrative wise as well I think. Then of course,
the 3Billion bounty fits in incredibly nicely with
luffy's path so far. He went form a 30 Million
Rookie bounty, to a 300 Million Warlord level
bounty to 1.5 Billion after defeating Katakuri,
in other words half a YOnko bounty. And now
he has officially entered the YOnko realm,
completing the 3 series with 3
Billion Berries on his flaming head.
Then of course, there is the question why
both Law and Kid have gotten the same bounty
as Luffy. Rightfully, you might say that Luffy
is the most powerful out of those 3. Now I was
honestly pretty surprised about this reveal as
well. However I really really like it honestly.
Similarly to Luffy, both Law and Kid deserve
90% of the credit for taking down Big Mom.
And I think the government valued the act of
taking out a YOnko here and not just power
scale everyone. Instead of splitting Luffy's
bounty and giving Law and Kid 1.5 Billion each,
they were looking at the alliance of these 3
captains as a whole and want to see all 3 of
them captured for the threat they now pose. It
also really nicely, and honestly unexpectedly,
sets up Law and Kid as true rivals to Luffy
for finding the One PIece. It suddenly gives
them a lot more relevance for the remaining
story than I would originally have suspected.
Plus it gives Luffy the chance to distinguish
himself from the two even more in the future.
Which is a really important point too I think,
that I'm actually pretty excited about. Giving
LUffy a mid-range Yonko bounty strongly
suggests to me that we will see at least
one more bounty poster for him at some point,
reaching the pinnacle of the pirate world. You
have to remember, that Luffy defeating the
world government will mean no more wanted
posters. And so I speculated before, that
Wano might well be the last increase we see
for all the straw hats. But no, it really
looks like we'll get at least one more.
Maybe after ELbaf or maybe even after Luffy
becomes the new pirate king, just like Roger.
Now in case you're STILL salty about LUffy
having the same bounty as Kid and Law,
I want to remind you, that the World Government
is very much aware of Luffy being the strongest
out of the three. DOn't forget how much they
fear the return of the sun god Nika. And so
I think they decided to not put that into his
bounty, but instead gave Luffy one of the now
two open spots among the four emperors, while Law
and Kid don't get that title. Luffy being a YOnko
is what really distinguishes him from the other
two. And if you don't believe me, just look at
Kid's reaction this chapter. He thinks exactly
the same. Of course he's just joking, I think,
when he says that he now has come for Luffy's
head, but he very much understands that the
government sees Luffy above him and Law. So
overall I do genuinely believe that the new
bounties are pretty much perfect, especially
with Luffy now being officially a Yonko.
I actually really that we only got these 3
bounties and the new Yonko reveal this chapter,
don't worry we'll get to buggy. But yeah, the fact
that all the straw hats have gotten new bounties,
but we will get those after the break is pretty
dope I think. That basically guarantees that we
will have a banger chapter right away after
the break and it also gives Oda an extra
week of breathing time, because I assume
1054 will be at least 50% bounty posters.
Now sadly, that won't include my
own wanted poster. Even though my
own bounty has raised from 59M to
60M recently after we hit 600.000
subscribers on the channel this week, because
every single subscriber equals 100 Berries on
top of my bounty! Honestly, thank you so so
much for your support. It means the world.
Especially since we have been at war with
this man here. Trebol, who still is almost
40M berries ahead of us. But we'Re coming
for you Trebol. We'll show you who's boss.
What I once again found super interesting is
how Big News Morgan is once again disobeying the
government censorship. While he got the official
bounties and the Yonko news from the gorosei,
he decided to print an image of Luffy in gear
5 on his wanted poster, basically publishing
LUffy's new godly appearance to the entire world.
A photo that CP0 managed to take during the fight.
I guess in an effort to let the cylinder
guy's death not be in vain. Understandably,
the Gorosei are furious about this leak. The
government has tried to erase the true nature of
the Nika fruit form history, and now its awakened
form will be seen in every single corner of the
world. This will be especially concerning, because
there are people out there who will know exactly
what they are looking at. I'm thinking, Shanks,
Rayleigh, maybe also Blackbeard and Dragon. In
other words, having some of the most powerful
and dangerous people in the world find out that
joy boy has returned, will make things even more
unstable for the government than it already was.
I actually also found it hilarious that apparently
the CP agents were taken out by Big Mom's ship.
Hilarious, because they were completely useless
for the entirety of the raid, but also because
it still makes me wonder wether Big Mom and
Kaido might not have survived somehow in the
end. And it also raises the question, what the
Big Mom pirates will do now that their leader
has been taken out. The beast pirates
have all been decimated after the raid,
especially with Greenbulls arrival. But the
big mom pirates are basically still fully
functional in full force. Will Katakuri
become their new captain? And how will he
react to Big Mom having been defeated? Will
he try to avenge her? Or join forces with
Luffy? For some reason I haven't really thought
about this before, but now I'm super curious.
And speaking of Greenbull: What the hell happened
there? It seems like King and Queen tried to fight
him and got completely decimated. Greenbull,
or Aramaki, as he's called, is an absolute
monster. It turns out that he doesn't use his
plant powers for photosynthesis to survive, but
instead he literally sucks the life force out of
his opponents to heal himself. This devil fruit,
whatever it is, might be one of the, if not
the most terrifying power I have seen in the
entirety of the story. Like just imagine what
you could do with it. Build entire cities if you
wanted to. IT's basically the one piece version of
Hashirama. His abilities are basically perfect to
take out a large amount of medium strong opponents
all at once. An incredibly precise, yet wide-range
attack. And on top of that he also seems to be a
swordsman, just like Issho, carrying what looks
to be a black blade. This once against makes me
wonder, if he's not actually someone from Wano.
Something else that might hint towards
that is his real life inspiration,
that people on the Internet were once again
super quick to find out. As you probably know,
all admirals are inspired by Japanese actors. And
Greenbull is no exception. He's the spiting image
of Yoshio Harada, a super famous Japanese actor,
who was especially known for two types of roles:
Rebells and Samurai. We can see the rebel
in him for constantly disobeying Akainu's
orders and the Samurai think once again
might hint at a connection with Wano.
Now I originally speculated, that
he might actually be a good guy,
who similarly to Aokiji will sympathise with
Luffy's cause. However after seeing how brutal
he is and how good he finds Akainu's extreme way
of doing things...I'm not so sure. He literally
says he's coming for Luffy's head. Now he might
still turn out to be a good guy or Zoro's father,
but it doesn't seem like it. Though honestly he
can be both, Zoro's father AND a bad guy. I have
a lot more thoughts about Greenbull, but I'll save
that for a whole video on him during the break.
Meanwhile, we have the major celebration going
on in the flower capital. Basically seeing the
start of the big banquet we have all been waiting
for. The best thing about this is how it shows how
much Luffy has grown throughout Wano and the New
World, while still being the very same person at
heart we first fell in love with. He doesn't want
to take away from Momo's moment and he sees all
the people of Wano eat and drink for free and as
much as they like, basically a mini version of his
dream that we got revealed just a few chapters
ago. It seems like becoming a Yonko and beating
Kaido has made luffy a little bit wiser, as
weird as it may sound in regards to Luffy.
But for some reason there is even more to this
chapter. Because in the secret basement, with the
dolls that we already had seen before, Robin, who
I'm happy to say has not been captured by anyone,
yet, has a conversation with Hitetsu, one of
the first characters we ever saw in Wano. Well
it turns out that he is actually Kozuki Sukiyaki,
Oden's father who we all had thought to be dead
for a long long time. This is such an interesting
reveal, because it opens up so many questions,
but since we barely get any answers here, I want
to move on to talking about Pluton. Robin. What
the heck. How did you know about Pluton being
in Wano since Alabasta and never mentioning
it once? Not only does this once again underline
the fact that Alabasta seems to have been allied
with the Ancient Kingdom in some way or form,
in this case specifically Wano, but it also
begs the important question once again: What is
Pluton? Is there a giant battleship hidden in
Wano? Or is it literally Momonosuke, just how
it was Shirahoshi on fishman island? I feel
like we might be getting some lore on the ancient
weapons in the story quite soon with this reveal.
But let's move on to my personal and I guess your
personal highlight of this entire chapter. This
right here. Who would have thought, that
the cover of volume 25 would foreshadow
the future 4 emperors of the sea for the 25th
anniversary of One Piece? Like rally Oda-sensei,
just how much did you actually plan this story
in advance? Is this an actual coincidence? Buggy
becoming an emperor of the sea is just the biggest
plot twist ever. It throws up so many questions:
How did that happen? Is buggy actually
just lucky or is he a secret master
mind? Was Buggy the pirate that shanks was
talking about to the Gorosei to distract
them from Luffy? I want to take my time and
discuss this in a whole video, but for now,
if you really want to understand how the
world government thinks and functions and
how the Gorosei rule the world, you should
not miss out on this video right here.